foreign
platform should articulate clearly what
their policies are what their standards
are for violence and harassment and
safety and then follow those standards
what happened is that so we have this um
elonjet account on Twitter and what it
does is it basically shows where elon's
jet is at any given moment in time so
he's been complaining about this account
for a while he offered money to the
person behind it Jack Sweeney if he
would take it down Jack Sweeney said no
but he made a counteroffer for more
there's a little back and forth
ultimately at this point now
um musk has just taken it down
altogether and I guess that and then the
Jack Sweeney's personal account as well
so that is how we got to this point
um Elon Musk is claims that it is a
matter of personal safety but I find
that claim not credible given that this
is publicly available data it's not
secret data it's pretty available and
I'm pretty sure he has pretty good
security around him
I think it's just being vindictive or
thorough I don't know if you could look
at it either way my first reaction is
this strikes me as entirely in keeping
with what we have been seeing over the
past several weeks which is that
um suspension and banning decisions are
just entirely arbitrary and capricious
on the one hand he is and the
corporation exercising their first
amendment rights which they are allowed
to do on the other hand I do think it's
not consistent with I think some of the
statements that he's made where he's
been very critical of content moderation
and I think what he's happening right
now is two things one is he's
discovering as have many before him that
content moderation is hard
um but then I think the other thing
that's happening is he's responding to
that by sort of throwing up his hands
and not even trying to do it well I mean
if you look at the fact that he
dissolved the trust and Safety Council a
couple of days ago he's fired most of
their trust and say safety staff who are
in charge of content moderation so it
seems that he's just given up and just
said well I'm just it's just going to be
my my whim
which is not I think going to be great
for Twitter users as a whole and it's
not just about this particular account
there are lots of journalists human
rights Defenders and other people around
the world that actually really depend on
Twitter in particular to communicate
pretty important information and when
you don't have transparency you don't
have consistency we're putting them in a
very difficult position which legally
you might have the right to do but I
think you know it's really not
appropriate or Fair what is fair though
is when you have a situation where you
have a clear and consistent policy and
you follow it clearly and consistently
and you allow a process for appeal so
notice an appeal and that none of that
seems to have happened here and none of
that seems to have happened with respect
to a lot of the decisions that are
getting made right now on Twitter
Twitter it gets complicated is with
these really big social media platforms
that are trying to host every different
kind of conversation and then trying to
have clear and consistent policies it's
a real Challenge and you can look at not
just Twitter but if you can look at
Facebook Facebook has been throwing
millions of dollars at content
moderation for a decade they still make
mistakes all the time
what this is really highlighting for
everybody is something that that we've
been concerned about for a while which
is that there's an enormous amount of
power over online speech that's
concentrated in relatively few hands so
not just Elon Musk but also you know
Mark Zuckerberg and and a few other
folks and that's not great that's
dangerous for overall speech because it
means that they just have so much power
to shape speech
I don't think that we want you know a
group of people based in Silicon Valley
to make decisions for the world about
speech I think that's very concerning I
think it is definitely going to keep
happening and the reason I think that is
because it's already been happening
already for the past month this is just
the latest instance but it seems very
clear that the decisions of who is on
Twitter and off Twitter basically
depends on the whims of Elon Musk on any
given day
so that is the new reality for Twitter
users and I suspect there will soon be a
lot fewer of them
foreign